>>Tony Chan: Sorry for the delay for this,
this week Android ADL Plus show.
My name is Tony Chan and I am a developer
advocate for Android.
I'm based out of Hong Kong and today I have
Anirudh here joining us for the show.
Anirudh?
>>Anirudh Dewani: Hi everyone.
I'm Anirudh from Hyderabad.
I know we are missing our regular anchor today.
It's just going to be me and Tony today.
So let me just give you a brief introduction
on the format of ADL Plus which is presented
to you by the APAC Android team here.
So we're gonna do a brief presentation on
an interesting topic that we're gonna pick
daily, every week, and then this will be followed
up by the Q&A of the questions you've been
asking us on the moderator.
>>Tony Chan: So, Anirudh, is the slide showing
up fine?
>>Anirudh Dewani: Yes, it is.
Thank you, Tony.
>>Tony Chan: Great.
>>Anirudh Dewani: Alright, so we'll kick off
the, we'll kick off the presentation.
So, first we've got news and I'll let Tony
present to you the news.
>>Tony Chan: Okay, so, we have couple news
this week and the first one we didn't mention
actually last week, Playstore is now having
gift cards and is now available in the US
and hopefully we can make it available, more
available in other countries.
The other, the other news on events, we have
a GDG, Google developer group tonight in Hong
Kong.
And coming up we have India, in India, in
New Delhi, we have an event coming up called
GIndia, it's on the September 4th and 5th
and Anirudh and I will have a sess- , two
sessions actually talking about Android on
the 5th.
Okay, so, I will pass it back to you Anirudh
to do the presentation for today.
>>Anirudh Dewani: Alright so this week we're
gonna be talking about MonkeyRunner, it's
a tool that is present in the Android SDK
tools folder.
It's not related to the monkey tool which
is used for straight UI testing.
MonkeyRunner is a different thing, it's a
tool that writes you an API and we'll see
how we can implement quality control on your
application using MonkeyRunner.
So, we'll move to the next slide.
Alright, so like I said, MonkeyRunner provides
and API for interfacing with devices.
What this means is you can connect to different
devices or emulators available or attached
to your system and you can basically sync
them all to inputs and we'll see, in detail,
what we can do.
So, it uses Jython which is an implementation
of Python that uses Java programming language.
So there are multiple options available to
you and it's how you wanna run your script,
you can go to an interactive session or you
can actually write the complete script and
run it through the tool that we provide.
So, also it's important to note that the code
runs on a different device that it's running
on your workstation where you have the SDK
and while running on your machine it controls
the attached devices, so it's not actually
running on the Android device.
The next thing is let's look at the capabilities
on MonkeyRunner.
So, like I said first, it allows you to connect
to multiple devices, not just one.
You can actually connect to multiple devices.
It can launch applications and activities.
It has APIs to help you do that, to start
activate in send bar [unintelligible].
You can also send touch events and keystrokes
which means you can provide input to your
running applications.
We'll show you a way to do that.
Also there is an API to help you take screenshots
so you can grab images of the application
running on the phone and you can script the
above operations in a sequence of commands
so you can just say, "Do this" and then sleep
for some time and then launch the activity
and then sleep again.
So you can write a complete script and run
it.
Okay, so let's move to the next slide.
So, since this session is dedicated on quality
control capabilities let's see what MonkeyRunner
can do.
So, basically there are two ways you can perform
testing on your applications using MonkeyRunner.
The first one is functional testing and, like
I said, you can write a script so it gives
you a fully automated test procedure where
you can perform an end to end test on your
application.
You can also execute use cases which are interactive
with input events.
The second thing it can allow you to do is
do regression testing.
So, I mentioned that you can take screenshots
from your application using MonkeyRunner so
what you can do is once you have a good bill
and you've done functional testing with a
good bill you can compare this with your daily
bill by taking screenshots and comparing the
screenshots to see if your UI is working fine.
So, now we will look at some of the key APIs
as in the code packages and models available
to you.
So the first one is MonkeyRunner, it's the
most important model.
It provides you static utilities to help you
obtain a device and obtain a major connection.
The second is the device.
Once you actually have MonkeyRunner giving
you a device object you can use the device
object to the present, uh, which actually
presents the attached device emulator and
start interacting with that device.
And third one is Monkey Image.
So this presents an image that you have grabbed
from a device or emulator using the snapshot
API.
Alright, so here's how you can launch the
MonkeyRunner interactive tool.
We are now looking at how to write some code
in MonkeyRunner.
So if you can see this is present in your
Android SDK tools folder, uh, tools folder
there's a tool called MonkeyRunner.
So as soon as you launch this you'll see an
interactive session, much like the Python
shell.
So this is where you can start, you know,
doing kind of hacking your way through MonkeyRunner,
exploring different APIs.
The other way is to write a script, so, when
you actually write a script, the procedure
is, the first thing you wanna do is when you
have, when you have a MonkeyRunner script
running the first thing you wanna do is connect
to a device and this is generally done with
one of the static utilities available in MonkeyRunner
and this is great for connection.
So once you do a way for connection this API
is a blocking call and will return you back
a Monkey device which is the device attached.
So once you have a connection to a device,
what you wanna do is install your APK.
Now, like I said, this is an end to end test
procedure so we're gonna, we're gonna do our
bill using our bill system and then we have
an APK and then we launch the MonkeyRunner
script to install the APK package onto the
device.
And, like I said, we can have multiple devices
and not just one device if you're testing
different configurations it can actually do
this for multiple devices.
So you do a call to install package onto the
device giving the part to your full APK and
this will help you install your package onto
the device.
Once you've installed your packages, what
you wanna do is probably launch your main
activity and the call that is available, the
API here is start activity and you pass the
component which is your, which comprises of
your package name and the main activity.
So, putting it all together you can see how
it goes.
So this is a small script that's actually
importing some of the modules that we talked
about.
There's a MonkeyRunner, there's a monkey device
and a time module to install, uh, to basically
allow the device to sleep for some time so
that if you're installing the device and it's
gonna take like five, ten seconds to install
the APK onto the device, you wanna do a sleep
for a while before you execute the next command.
So this is, this is the module to help us
with that.
So as you can see the first call there was
MonkeyRunner.waitforconnection and the three,
yeah, the three things that we discussed on
how you wanna begin testing.
Alright, so once you've installed the APK
and you launch the main activity on MonkeyRunner,
what you wanna do is and automated rig.
You wanna send some touch inputs or type text
or send inputs.
So this can be done using a touch, uh, using
a touch API and when you send an X and Y coordinate
of where you wanna generate the touch image
and the type of touch.
So, for example, this can be down and up so
this is a touch where you press down and up
and then there is a type text which is basically
used if you have an input field on the screen
and you wanna put in some text in an automated
way.
So as you can see now we are executing our
use cases on how we want to test our app using
some of the MonkeyRunner input APIs.
Alright so, so now we begin, we've installed
our APK onto the device, we've launched our
main activity and we've sent some input commands
and we're going through our screens.
So at this point, for functional testing,
what you wanna do is take a snapshot.
This is basically, it's gonna give you a screenshot
of what's on your screen right now in your
device or emulator and as an imagine and the
object that's representing this is the monkey
image and you can write this to a file for
if you wanna do regression testing if you
wanna see if something's changed between my
last bill and this you can compare the images
from the snapshots using this.
So here's a tip, there's a very popular Unix
Magic and there has a compare ability so you
can run this program and it can help you compare
images and ascertain regression testing.
So, um, now we're gonna look at the script
all together so you see the complete script
and this is all available on the Android developer
website.
So if you go there and look for tools and
MonkeyRunner you're gonna see a lot of APIs
and links and documentation.
So this is a script from the website and as
you can see this just puts together what we've
been doing.
So, we install a package, we run the main
activity and then we start the activity, we
send the key code menu which is just pressing
the menu button onto the device and then we
take a snapshot on how our menu item looks
on the screen and then you just write the
file to a disc.
So, a very simple script, it's something you
can start with.
If you don't wanna run the script what you
can do is just, like I said, mention you can
go to an interactive shell and using the interactive
shell you can just start typing UIs, start
touch inputs here and there, figure out the
buttons, figure out the X and Y positions
and then write a complete script that can
be conformed.
So, uh, so these are what we discussed, ways
of doing functional testing which is executing
your use cases remotely in an automated way
using scripts but there is more to MonkeyRunner
than functional and regression testing.
So you can also extend the API by writing
your own plug-ins in Java language.
There are some utilities like device.shell;
it's a MonkeyRunner UI.shell which can send
APK commands to your device.
You can also use the standard parts and sub
processing and [inaudible] modules to launch
extended program.
Again, you can launch ADB and send commands
for ADB using the sub processor and [inaudible]
modules.
And, again, there is also a Java API which
is available as MonkeyRunner.JR and this JR
file is present in your tools folder of SDK
and it also has a program, a sample, a swing
app, a Java swing app that basically allows
you to remote control your device using a
screenshot grabbing utility, it grabs a screenshot
every 5 seconds and you can click on somewhere
on the screenshot and it figures out the X
and Y from the, from the, uh, sample app,
the swing app and then it sends the same coordinates
to generate, attach on the actual device using
Java APIs.
So, that's another example you can look at.
Yeah, so, let me just summarize here of what
we have discussed using MonkeyRunner tool
as a way of performing quality control in
our application, as a way of controlling multiple
devices in a test environment where you can
execute your test cases, end to end test cases
and you can also extend this API.
So, with this, we come to the end of MonkeyRunner
presentation.
If you have questions about this please feel
free to ask us now if you're joining the hangout
or you can post these questions on the next
week's Google moderator link for the ADL Plus
show and we'll definitely answer your questions
there.
So with this, we'll move to this week's Q&A
and Tony, if you can, start up in Q&A.
>>Tony Chan: Yeah, sure.
Thanks Anirudh for showing us the MonkeyRunner.
So, we have quite a few questions this week
so let's start to talk about some of these
questions.
So, the first question is from Ivan, um, "So
there is a serious memory leak in map view
that cause crashes when used for map in one
direction for some time with the link.
It's not yet solved and the first submission
was like 3 years ago.
Is there any hope that this will be solved?"
So we understand the map, uh, that map view
is kind of out of date and we are aware of
that and we are working, our engineering team
is working to improve that.
At the moment we don't have anything to share
but, um, unfortunately.
If we have anything we can announce we will
let you guys know as soon as possible.
So the next question, uh, Anirudh, can you
take the next question?
>>Anirudh Dewani: Sure.
So, the question is, "Why can't Android app
developers from India and China send their
apps on Google apps market?"
I guess what you're referring to this is the
Playstore.
"What are the alternatives available for such
developers?
Will this restriction be ever lifted?
If so, when?"
So, uh, so I'll talk about India and then
later Tony can talk about China cause he's
more familiar with that market there.
So what are the alternatives available to
such developers?
To begin with I wanna mention that as a developer
you can still register on developer.com with
Google Play and you can upload your apps,
they have to be free apps for now which is
a restriction, but you can still use some
of our ads offerings for revenue.
That's one option, an alternative to, for
revenue.
The other one is, I know some developers that
actually have bank accounts in different countries
which you're allowed for selling apps on Google
Playstore and you will probably have to consult
your tax consultants and, to figure out if
that works, but I know some developers actually
do that.
The other alternative available to you is
to find a partner in a country which actually
has access to the Playstore to sell apps there
and enter into a partnership where you can,
you can be the developer and the partner can
take care of distribution needs of the application.
Tony, if you have something add.
>>Tony Chan: Yeah, so, for China it's kind
of similar issues like getting payment enabled
in the country is involves a lot of policy
and it's more than just technical issue.
So, again, like I said and Anirudh mentioned
we see a lot of developer they have partnerships
or business partners in countries that we
do support Google Wallet and that's how they
set up their developer account.
And in China that would be a similar situation.
So, yeah.
So the next question is, uh, "Are there any
restriction in Google Play preventing application
sold by charity to source donations?
I have reviewed the Google Play terms of service
and not found any obvious issues."
So, in general, what Steve mentioned is correct.
So there's no policy on the Google Play site
to prevent developer to create apps that source
donation.
That said, for Google Wallet does have certain
policy in terms of receiving payment for donation
and so you have to be a US 501C3 or 501C6
nonprofit organization and there is a process
in order to receive donation you have to,
we have to verify you are a certified charity
organization as you claim.
So, um, I think in short you have to be a
501C3 or 6 organizations.
So, the next question, Anirudh?
>>Anirudh Dewani: Yeah Tony, so the question
is from JDixon from Western Australia, "I
have 8 plus years of Java dev But I'm new
to Android.
I wrote this" and it's a link to a spinner
example, "on the difficulty I had mapping
spinner user to system user via Android.
Did I miss something?"
So I did take a brief look at the link that
you've shared and went through some of the
code and notes and it looks fine for what
you're trying to do there.
But, yeah, and I, you also mentioned in your
example that one way to do that is to actually
use a system resource from Spring store XML
use an item to map it to spinner which is
what we see very commonly used and you can
use that.
So I see what you were trying to do is attach
some listener so you can do some length checks
and actually use system menu which sounds
fairly, which sounds okay to me.
It's very simple to use the spinner with an
add in from Spring store XML from a data source
from, adaptor from a data source.
It's pretty difficult if you, we have some
examples on our developer.Android.com website.
Yeah.
>>Tony Chan: Okay, cool, um, thanks.
And, um, so Steve just back to your, uh, the
donation question so I just noticed you are
from Melbourne so if you are interested in
creating apps for international charity that
may be, I need to check with the Google Wallet
team and see whether we allow that.
So, if you are interested to find out for
nonprofit organization outside of the US send
us a post in G Plus or send me a post and
we can follow up with you.
So the next question I have here is from William,
"How do I get a user identified for an in
app billing transaction so I can collate and
manage transactions on my server?
The identity just need to be unique with my
app but needs to span multiple devices and
no permission beyond Google Play."
So, I think, William mentioned quite few key
points here.
Just for general audience benefit, Google,
uh in Google Play we have two types of digital
in app purchase products.
So, one is we call a unmanaged products and
another type is managed products.
So for the managed products, um, Google Play
server does actually manage the user to restore
like all the information if someone reinstalled
a game and developer in the application call,
and call, the recall transaction methods in
the in app billing API to retrieve all the
previous, like, purchase items.
So that's done, taken care of in the API.
But what William mentioned is those unmanaged
items which is not managed by Google, in that
case, I think our general recommendation is
not to create any, the unique identifier has
to be something like, um, we recommend using
the UUID and we actually have an article if
you search Google, search for, talk about
how to identify a user and we specifically
discourage user to use device ID or IMBI or
things like that or even the app, Android
app ID which is really[OEM depends on the
implementation of OEM.
It could not, may not be unique.
So UUID is the recommendation, um, I guess
the key question is how do we persist that
UUID and how to retrieve that information
when the user sign in to a new device.
So something is coming up soon, what we call
Google Play service and Google Play service,
we will have a implementation of OAuth2 as
well as the Google Plus API and with OAuth2
it will be very easy for developer to talk
to a lot of the Google, different APIs at
Google.
So one, just idea, is you can store the UUID
or definitely have the user, in Google drive
and using OAuth to authenticate and then you
can, you can retrieve the ID and use that
to connect back to your server, link the ser-,
link the user to retrieve all the necessary
unmanaged products information.
So that's one idea we have here.
Anything you want to add Anirudh?
>>Anirudh Dewani: Uh, yeah, I'm not really
an expert there so I think you've covered
it well there.
>>Tony Chan: Okay.
So, Anirudh, why don't you take the other
question, the next question?
>>Anirudh Dewani: Yes, the next question is
from [inaudible] from [inaudible], "Hi, I'm
developing iPhone app so here I integrated
Google Plus but here everywhere we need user
ID.
Please tell me how to get user ID.
Thank you."
So, going on, I'm sorry we don't have much
expertise with iPhone here so can't really
answer your question here and this is just
targeted at Android developers.
In terms of Google Plus, again, we are not
really not experts on Google Plus APIs but
you can feel free to browse their website
and they may have some APIs there listed.
Thank you.
>>Tony Chan: Okay, so I'll take the next question.
It's from Sameer and "Which is the best, cheapest
Android tablet with call function?"
I guess that's really another developer question
and probably you can ask your friends and,
we don't have any recommendation here.
Okay, let's go to the next question, the last
question for today.
"Does paid Google translate API provide better
quality than free online Google translate?"
Um, again, this is a developer question but
we are mainly focusing on Android here.
But since Anirudh and I are nicer so we do
actually research an answer for you.
So first of all the translate API is a paid
API so there is no free options there and
in terms of quality, I would suggest you to
ask that question on the Google translate
API forum.
So there is a forum and probably you can,
there is also a contact form to the paid,
to the, uh, to the pay support team and you
may want to ask the answer there.
But, however, our guess is actually the API
is probably the same as the one provided on
the Google translate site so, but check with
the support team.
Alright, that's, that seems like that's all
we have for today.
I guess if there's like, Anirudh is there
anything you wanna cover or?
>>Anirudh Dewani: Not really.
So, what we'll do is we'll share some links
to resources for MonkeyRunner in case you
wanna go through them and thank you for joining
us today.
We don't have any light questions today so
I think that'll be it.
>>Tony Chan: Okay.
Thanks so much.
Thank you.
Bye bye.
>>Anirudh Dewani: Bye.
>>Tony Chan: See you next week.